it is now exactly one month since the
liberal establishment from the media all
the way up to the White House labeled me
genocidal for saying that men don't
belong in women's bathrooms
genocide is in fact not one of my
favorite things
I am not genocidal genocide is among my
least favorite things right up there
with plague famine and tofu I don't like
any of them but the irony of the
Liberals defaming me is genocidal is
that there is a genocide occurring in
our country right now and the Liberals
are the perpetrators and the genocide is
called abortion
through the abortion genocide liberals
have murdered more than 60 million
Americans since Roe v Wade established a
nationwide license to abortion in 1973.
this genocide has disproportionately
targeted and killed black Americans we
only have reliable racial demographic
data for abortions in 26 States in
almost all of them the percentage of
abortion victims who are black vastly
outnumbers the black percentage of the
population
in about a quarter of the states for
which we have reliable numbers black
people constitute an outright majority
of abortion victims despite constituting
just thirteen and a half percent of the
U.S population in certain cities such as
New York more black babies are murdered
in the womb than are born
in 2020 about 10 000 black people were
murdered with guns knives bats Hammers
and the like in the United States
that same year at least at least 242
000 black people were murdered through
abortion and owing to Under reporting
the true number of black abortion
victims that year is certainly much
higher even using the most conservative
statistics available 24 times as many
black people were murdered through
abortion as through all other means
combined this is not a bug of the
abortion genocide but a central feature
as planned parenthood founder Margaret
Sanger made clear when she wrote in a
1939 letter to one of her program
directors quote we do not want word to
go out that we want to exterminate the
negro population
black people have been
disproportionately targeted and killed
by abortion but the genocide has claimed
victims of all Races localities and
social strata the genocide is ongoing
but the death toll of abortion is
already larger than any non-abortion
related genocide in history by at least
an order of magnitude its perpetrators
have defended this campaign on the
grounds that such Slaughter constitutes
some sort of right but of course there
can be no such right to murder someone
because murder is wrong and Wrongs are
not rights pretty simple very simple
now what is a right a right
is a moral or legal authority to possess
claim or use a thing as one's own a
right signifies the object of Justice
and Justice is a moral quality or habit
which perfects the will and inclines it
to render to each and to all what
belongs to them
I don't mean to be pedantic but today
many people no longer know the meaning
of basic words they don't know the
meaning of the word man and woman and so
I think it's probably prudent to Define
more abstract Concepts such as right and
Justice especially for the liberal
operatives who are watching right now
out in YouTube land that for those
people I found it's very good to speak
slowly and make it nice and easy to
digest so we have rights and Justice
what does all that mean practically
the Liberals claim an implausible right
to abortion based on a somewhat more
plausible right to do whatever one
pleases with one's own body we'll get to
more of that in just a moment in the
case of abortion according to the
Liberals there is a conflict between two
rights the baby's right not to be
murdered and the mother's right to
control her own body in the familiar
language of the Declaration of
Independence the the conflict that the
Liberals view here is between the baby's
right to life and the mother's right to
Liberty or to the pursuit of happiness
but even according to this liberal
framing abortion is not defensible
because the right to life is not merely
one right among many
the right to life is the fundamental
right without which none of the other
rights are possible Thomas Jefferson did
not list life liberty and the pursuit of
happiness at random without life there
can be no Liberty without Liberty one
cannot pursue happiness even according
to the liberal framework it would be
incoherent to claim that one's right to
Liberty trumped another's right to life
since the right to Liberty depends upon
the right to life now
the liberal view is wrong because the
right to life and the right to Liberty
can never be in opposition as the
Liberals mistakenly believe this is
because Liberty is not the right to do
whatever one chooses but rather the
right to do what one ought to do there
has been no better explanation of this
true nature of freedom and slavery than
the explanation given in the gospel of
Saint John when Christ observes that the
man who sins is a slave to sin
you do not need to be a practicing
Christian or even to believe in God to
understand this fact all you have to do
is look at the nearest drug adult bum
according to the liberal view the heroin
addict in San Francisco is the freest
man in the world he can shoot up
whenever he wants the cops won't arrest
him as long as he can lay his hands on a
couple of bucks and he can score some
dope and shoot it into his veins he can
pass out on the street and die of
exposure or of an overdose isn't he so
free
no I don't think so the heroin addict is
among the least free people in the world
he is a slave to his addiction
as are all addicts as are all people
because Vice and virtue are both habits
and the longer one performs any habit
the harder it is to break the Liberals
fraudulent notion of Liberty also known
as licentiousness is nothing more than
slavery to sin which leads to spiritual
and often physical death
so you can't kill babies okay now this
is the point of the debate when liberals
unable to defend abortion will often
attempt to deflect from this failure by
bringing up the mostly unrelated point
of capital punishment they will say oh
okay there Mr Conservative you're so
pro-life tell me what you think about
the death penalty huh got you there
I like it that's the spoiler alert I
like the death penalty a lot and
contrary to what some of these glib Libs
seem to think there is no hypocrisy in
simultaneously opposing abortion and
supporting the death penalty
in fact each follows naturally from the
other as the ultimate argument against
abortion is the same ultimate argument
in favor of the death penalty namely
that man is made in the image and
likeness of God
chickens and bugs and rutabaga do not
have a special right to life you would
not be guilty of murder for eating a
Chick-fil-A sandwich or for stepping on
an ant or for doing with rutabaga
whatever one does with rutabaga
those things I don't really know what
rutabaga is I just kind of like the word
it sort of sounds funny those things
however are all created and alive but
they are not made in the image and
likeness of God
they have souls proper to their nature
because the soul is the principle of
life but they do not have a rational
Soul they do not possess someone seems
to object to my defense of life I think
there are a lot of people who do but
we'll have to explain it anyway a lot of
people try to shout this sort of thing
down because because there is not much
of an argument against it so we maybe
not the Heckler but we the rest of us
possess intellect and will and that is
why why we don't put ants on trial for
biting us that's why we don't arrest
chickens for clucking too loudly animals
lack the intellect you can see the
abstract Concepts such as Justice and
they lack the will to discipline their
appetites to respect and pursue Justice
well we don't arrest chickens for
clucking but I do think we ought to you
know how I could have told that that guy
was going to be a problem you know how I
could have told because he's wearing a
mask and it was always very ridiculous
to wear a mask it was always very
ridiculous but it's especially
ridiculous in this moment that's all
right his little whistle isn't too loud
so I think we can probably get through
it foreign
do aborted babies go to heaven
well it's a complex issue there's
there's the matter of limbo
you're right but there's the matter of
limbo because well I don't think he
really cares about an explanation of
this but if anyone's interested in the
finer points of Catholic theology I'm
more than happy to discuss them
afterward anywho all right enough of
that guy so
uh what what the Liberals will
frequently say is that these these
animals have rights but they don't
really have rights because they lack
intellect and will human beings do have
intellect and will and because we
conceive of right and wrong and good and
bad because we can Will to do good even
when our appetites attract us to things
that are bad as that poor man's appetite
has attracted him we can be held morally
responsible for our actions as I suspect
he is about to be held responsible for
his actions
and we must be held morally responsible
or else society would cease to function
law would lose its Force reason would be
ostracized from public life as it was
ostracized from his head and government
government would mean nothing more than
the law of the Jungle According to which
the strong dominate the weak through
sheer Brute Force
this is why the Bible establishes the
rationale for capital punishment in one
of the earliest chapters of the very
first book and the argument is whosoever
sheds the blood of Man by man shall his
blood be shed it does not say whoever
blows a whistle in my face shall have
his Bloodshed that might be tempting but
that's not that would not be just at all
but whoever sheds the blood of Man by
man shall his blood be shed for God made
man in his own image man's rational soul
is the reason for protecting the
innocent as well as for punishing the
guilty up to and including capital
punishment it is because human life has
special value that we must punish people
who endanger it so we have no right to
kill babies
but we do have a right through the Civil
authority to kill criminals okay what
else can the right to life teach us
abortion Advocates like to chant the
phrase not your body not your choice and
that slogan ironically undercuts their
own argument as the baby's body is
obviously not the mother's body and the
mother therefore does not have the right
to choose to murder her baby by
destroying his body
but the slogan reveals a deeper truth as
well and one that in recent years has
been neglected by the right as well as
by the left
and that is that the baby's body is not
entirely the babies either and the
mother's body is not entirely the
mothers and your body is not entirely
yours either
one of the most bizarre euphemisms for a
woman that has emerged out of the
transgender movement is the term vulva
owner have you heard that I'm not making
that up it's a real term it's not just
being used in the fringes of the
Internet by some online weirdos is being
used by weirdos in newsrooms and
journalistic Outlets it's being used in
supposedly scientific Publications
it's absurd not only because it attempts
to avoid the simple word woman but also
because what it describes isn't real
there is no such person as a vulva owner
or any other kind of body part owner we
are in part our bodies but we do not own
our bodies
we didn't make our bodies we're going to
have to surrender our bodies at the
moment of our death whether we want to
or not and in the meantime there are all
sorts of things that we might wish to do
with our bodies that we're not allowed
to do
you might wish to be like the guy in San
Francisco and shoot up heroin but in
most places for now at least you have no
right to do it
you might wish to sell yourself into
slavery people have weird Kinks these
days you have no right to do that that
pesky 13th Amendment will get in your
way
you might even wish to kill yourself I
hope you don't but you might and most
places for now at least recognize that
you have no right to suicide if you
really owned your body real absolute
ownership you would have the right to do
those things
but you don't
now in recent years liberals have
attempted to overturn these prohibitions
with some success but there are now as
there always have been in every society
everywhere for all of history all sorts
of legal restrictions on what you're
allowed to do with your body that's
because our forebears used their
intellect to discern what is good and
true and then use their will to enshrine
their conclusions into law and to
enforce those laws for the common good
liberals recoil from this fact liberals
recoil for many facts but they
especially recoil from this one they
think this sort of talk smacks of
religion that's what that poor Heckler
was thinking about he said I don't want
to hear about religion I don't want to
hear about good and bad well it does
smack of religion our founding fathers
made no bones about it The Men Who Built
our country spelled it all out in our
founding documents not just the
Declaration of Independence which
defines the nation by our creator who
endows us with certain unalienable
rights but all of our founding documents
from the Mayflower Compact at our
earliest founding all the way up to
Lincoln's second inaugural in the
refounding of the Civil War
and what they all said is that our
rights our freedoms our whole political
order ultimately rest upon God to whom
we are accountable and to whom we
ultimately belong
people who do not consider themselves
religious might not like to hear it but
it is an inevitable fact it is the basis
of our law of all law actually that
certain things are better than other
things which implies an objective and
intelligible moral order which implies
an intelligent being who established
that order objectively before any of us
ever came onto the scene more simply it
is an observable fact Apparent from the
natural world our life body included is
not something that we made ourselves or
freely chose it is a gift given to us by
our maker that entails certain rights as
well as certain obligations
which brings us
to the the topic
not the topic of this lecture tonight
but the topic that everyone talks about
the topic that nobody seems able to shut
up about because the left is so
insistent enforcing it upon us you know
the topic
the topic over which our literally
genocidal liberal establishment
implausibly accused me little old me
whom everybody loves so of promoting
genocide one month ago what is that
topic
transgenderism of course
the Liberals went apoplectic over my
CPAC speech because they thought they
had already won on transgenderism and it
seemed that they had
a little over a month ago the debate
over transgenderism hinged on whether
the Liberals ought to be able to trans
the eight-year-olds or if they had to
wait until the kids turned nine
the debate hinged on whether quack
doctors and pervert teachers ought to be
able to preach trans ideology to third
graders or only to the fourth grade up
and I pointed out that the real question
of transgenderism is simply whether it
is true or false
if transgenderism is true
and a man really can somehow be a woman
then it's true for everyone of all ages
if it's false if men and women really
are different
then it's false for everyone too and if
it's false as it obviously is then we
shouldn't reorder our public life to
pretend that it's true we shouldn't take
women's bathrooms away from women we
shouldn't Force little girls to shower
with men in the locker room or to give
up their trophies and scholarships to
men who are much physically stronger
than they are
and we shouldn't butcher
Ed men and women of any age the Liberals
shrieked oh how they shrieked they're
still shrieking they're always shrieking
but they're shrieking especially over
this issue because we are reminding them
as a loving parent sometimes has to
remind an irrational and petulant
toddler that we live in society and
Society exists in reality which means
that we necessarily live within limits
and one of those limits is that men
cannot be women
I'm not
I'm not Francisco Franco over here okay
I'm not advocating some rigid political
program
I'm just observing a basic fact of
reality
a man will never no matter how hard he
tries ever make himself into a woman and
no one can be said to have the right or
even ability to contradict objective
reality without which rights would not
mean anything at all
this is the silver lining in the storm
cloud of transgenderism the issue
because it is so absurd helps to clarify
other political truths
it helps to clarify the leftist
political project which the former
communist Whittaker Chambers described
in his Memoir Witness
Chambers observed that communism
all modern leftism I think we can say is
not the newest political ideology but
the oldest
the ideology that began in the Garden of
Eden when the serpent told Eve ye shall
be his gods
it's attempting deceit but it's deceit
nonetheless
it's the lie that Milton Satan tells
himself in Paradise Lost when he
declares the mind is its own place and
in itself can make a heaven of Hell a
hell of Heaven here at least we shall be
free here we may Reign secure and in my
choice to Reign is worth ambition though
in hell
he's saying that radical autonomy is
worth losing all hope
even knowing that such autonomy will
make you miserable
better to reign in hell he concludes
than serve in heaven
it is the lie that once embraced can
make even prosperous Nations quickly
turned to Hell on Earth
I saw a poll recently from the Pew
Research Center found that an increasing
number of Americans believe in hell
a decreasing number of Americans believe
in God but an increasing number of
Americans believe in hell and I kind of
get it actually it's because they watch
the news and nothing good ever comes on
to the news you can deny good things but
but the evil is apparent right right
before you it's very difficult to deny
the existence of evil so a viral video
recently that depicted that fact all too
clearly it was a video of a young woman
who had had an abortion
and in her video she did not complain
about any attack on women's rights or
the campaign against women's health care
or any of the other slogans that one
usually hears instead she was lamenting
that no one had warned her of how
terrible she would feel after the
abortion she said quote no one tells you
how hard abortions are on a woman it's
probably been a month and I hate myself
every day
she said it sucks because in the moment
I felt like I was doing the right thing
but every time I'm going to bed or just
alone I think about what if
she was crying because she learned too
late
that the liberal promise of total
Liberation was an illusion no matter how
hard she tried she couldn't free herself
from her own conscience
this is why transgender activists are
constantly angry and increasingly
violent this is why last week they
promoted a trans day of vengeance
it's a telling choice of words wouldn't
you say not Justice vengeance
Justice demands that men stay out of
women's bathrooms
Justice is concerned with objective
reality and the role in rights that
people have in it
vengeance is all about the self
it demands violence against people who
won't surrender to the whims and desires
of vengeful people
and it is ultimately self-defeating
the old proverb says that the man out
for vengeance ought to dig two graves
vengeance is unjust because it claims a
right to repay which belongs not to us
but to God
the politics of Vengeance of liberation
of selfishness
is self-defeating because no one can
flourish in Rebellion against reality
I once heard all of leftism described in
three words as screw you Dad and I think
it summed it up for me that's I have
many liberal friends I've known many
liberals in my life and I would say
that's a common theme this is why the
physician who pioneered the transgender
surgery ended up shutting down his
clinic this is why rates of detransition
are skyrocketing this is why rates of
anxiety depression and suicide remain
virtually unchanged even after the
transgender transition because reality
Remains the Same
regardless of our delusions a baby does
not cease to be a baby simply because
his mother wants to kill it
a man does not cease to be a man simply
because he wishes to be a woman
when liberals say not your body not your
choice they mean that we can't know or
do anything about matters that don't
directly involve us
but of course we can
that is the premise of self-government
that is the meaning of the rational soul
that is the defining fact of human
nature
we can ascertain truths with our
intellect and we can enforce them with
our will we all have the ability to
perceive reality and to live in a way
conducive to our flourishing but none of
us has the right to redefine reality
because reality doesn't belong to us
we are not in fact gods and the tragic
pretense that we are can only lead to
Madness frustration and death we have
before us a choice
that much is true and I'm not the first
to say it
that choice is between life and death
blessing and cursing choose life
therefore real life that we and our
descendants may live